In case anybody was just wondering what's going on,
my daughter did get in the goddamn musical.
I didn't understand how it works.
Um, she didn't get a call back for one of the roles that she wanted.
Like, it's.
I think they're doing Cinderella or some shit,
and she obviously, she wanted one of the. Oh,
that's right. She was trying out for one of the stepsisters.
Cutely, because when we had.
One of my daughters had a make A wish trip,
she has a congenital heart disease,
and she's a make A wish kid.
So we got sent to Disney World,
and the stepsisters were one of our favorite characters to meet,
so that's why it was, like,
really special to her to. And I always sing the stepsister songs.
Like, that's a thing in our House.
Sweet, Sweet Night.
So that's why I was triple hurt, because, like,
I always sing, like,
the stepsisters, and it's, like,
special to our family. Kinda like it has a little meaning.
So she was trying out for one of the stepsisters.
She didn't get a call back for the part,
like, a named part in the musical,
but she did get cast in the ensemble.
So she is gonna get to be on stage,
she's gonna get to sing, and she's,
you know, there are no small parts.
She's gonna be one of the other voices that's like, oh,
helping it to be a great production.
I felt bad that I missed the audition,
and I didn't get to, like,
cheer her on before the audition, but, um,
everything worked out anyway.